some
over e
okay
folks there are quite a few quizzes that
haven't been picked up yet so again I'm
going to leave them out for a few more
days before I bring them in so if you
haven't picked up your quiz please do so
um your case is due a week from
Wednesday right so if you haven't read
the case time to do it if you have read
the case it's actually going to help you
because as we go through these class
there'll be moments you say okay that
connects okay so let's continue with our
discussion we're talking about the Rio
Disney theme park and I work through the
numbers remember your job is to be the
decision maker you just just have to
decide whether to invest in this project
or not I work through the numbers in my
first iteration I thought like an
accountant I measured the earnings on
the project I measured what's invested
on the project from an accounting
perspective Book value and I came up
with an accounting return on Capital not
rocket science dividing the after tax
operating income by the invested capital
and my return on cap for this project
was
4.18% so this is the slide I left you on
what what should I compare the 7.18 I'm
sorry the 4.18% to to make a judgment on
whether to take the project now when we
talk about discount rates we very
Loosely use the word opportunity cost
which kind of means something but it
means nothing if you don't clarify
opportunity cost in what sense so
McKenry help me out when I say the
opportunity cost what is it that I need
to add on to make sure I get it right so
what is an
opportunity finish that off best
investment you can make given the risk
of what you're comparing it to right
because if you don't add that you're
saying well I I can invest my money so
the let's go through one by one and see
what the right choices are what's why is
the risk free rate not the opportunity
cost for this
investment Derek
because there's additional risk I'm
comparing apples to oranges I'm going to
cross that up okay the cost of equity is
not the opportunity cost and this is a
little technicality think of how I
measured the return on Capital I took
operating income income before interest
expenses and divided by invested Capital
which comes from both debt and Equity
it's a measure of return on total
Capital invested so I can't compare to
the cost of equity because it's not
apples and apples I've got to compare it
to the cost of capital
which effectively brings me down to two
choices should I compare to the cost of
capital for the entire company or should
I compare to the cost of capital with
theme parks an okayi what do you
think which cost of capital should I
compare this
to you got a 50/50 shot I'll help you
out if you get the wrong choice
company's cost of capital
or cost of capital the part
go back to what you know what we ear
mckendry said the opportunity cost is
what you will invest in a project of
equivalent risk right if you take that
to the next step the cost of capital you
should be comparing it to should be the
cost of capital for the the theme parks
because the theme park
investment so if I were to pick one
number here it would be
6.61% because that is the cost of
capital for this particular investment
when I first started teaching corporate
finance we used to do Capital budgeting
first that's what I was taught to do and
then we went to risk and return and
discount rates and it never made sense
to me because how can you talk about the
net present value of a project to the
return Project without bringing in what
the hurdle rate for that project should
be so if I had to pick one number it be
6.61% but there's one qualifier I'm
going to add where were Disney's
existing theme parks in
2013 Orlando Anaheim Tokyo
Paris Hong Kong had just opened up but
almost entirely in developed markets
right where's this thing Park going to
be in R is there some additional risk
that Disney's going to be exposed to
absolutely in fact there are two
additional risks that Disney's exposed
to when it invests in the Rio Disney
theme park Patrick what are the what
first first what what give me one of the
two risks it's exposed to but there's a
country risk Brazil is clearly a RIS
riskier environment invest in what's the
other that you expose yourself to
anytime you invest outside your own
country there foreign exchange risk
right currency risk I'm going to argue
we have to treat those two risk
differently and here's why the exchange
rate risk that comes from investing
outside I'm not worried about as Disney
you remember the top 17 investors in
Disney they're all institutional
investors can Black Rock take care of
itself when it comes to absolutely
they invest across the world the dollar
strengthens some companies are helped
some are hurt exchange rate risk is
diversifiable to the marginal investors
at least in Disney now if you're a
smaller privately held company or a
closely help publicly traded company You
could argue that this might not be the
case you have to bring in exchange rate
risk but exchange rate risk to a
publicly traded company where the
investors are globally Diversified as
Disney is is going to go away everybody
agree with that rashna so when I'm
investing in if this had been Disney
Frankfurt not Disney Rio I'd have used a
6.61% cost of capital and said you know
what it's a foreign market I've
exchanged rate risk but I'm not worried
the country risk is another Beast all
together that is additional risk that
will affect my earnings and cash flows
that is not diversifiable and I have to
bring that risk into my discount rate
this is where I'm going next right I
have to add something something to my
6.61% to capture the additional
risk but by now we've already talked we
had a quiz on Country Risk by now we
know how to deal with country risk so
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
go back and recalculate the cost of
capital for the theme park
business with a Brazil country risk
embedded in that cost of capital sounds
like I'm going to do something
sophisticated but here's all I did the
risk free rate still stays 2.75% I'm
still doing things in US dollar have spt
to us the beta is still the ba of a
theme parks that doesn't change the only
number that I changed was I instead of
using my us Equity risk premium or
Disney's Equity risk premum I use the
the equity risk premum that I'd account
come for Brazil as a country by adding
that additional country risk premium to
my mature Market premium 8.5% much
higher Equity risk premium much higher
cost of equity and leading to so
everything else in the equation stays
the same but I bring bringing country
risk into my cost of
equity already you can see if you're a
multinational and you work entirely US
Dollars your hurdle rate for the same
project in different parts of the world
is going to be different because of
differences in country risk and that
intuitively makes sense I should be
charging more for a project in a risky
country than I do in a safer Country and
this becomes the vehicle I use to bring
it
in any questions on the 8.46% cost of
Capal so from this point on you have
your hurdle rate remember you're the
decision maker you need to make
8.46% what is this project making 4.18%
right looks like a
no-brainer this is a bad project reject
the
project but before you do that there's
one one thing I need to add about that
4.18% do you remember how many years are
projected our earnings to get to 4.18%
I stopped in your 10 why did I stop in
your 10 you know that half of all
projects in the US have lifetimes of 10
years what happens at the end of your 10
do projects just fall
apart there a good reason you think what
do you think 10e life you see it in
valuations you see it in Project
analysis that's magical right why not 9
why not
12 it seems a little little arbitrary
doesn't it nice round number maybe this
is just me cynical me being cynical but
I think 10 is what fits comfortably
going
landscape on a page if you're printing
off a table you thinking that is so
absurd you know how infuriating it is to
have one extra column popping up an
extra page and this is before the days
you could shrink to
fit there's no good reason why I stopped
after your 10 you got to stop somewhere
I know but the reason reason I bring
that up is if you go back and look at
the pattern of returns over time notice
that the returns rise as I go from year
one to 10 if I pull this out to 15
years my return on capital is going to
go up right 20 years even more say
that's going to be true for any
investment but in this case I think
there's a reason that 10 years is really
hurting my
project how old is Disneyland as a theme
Parker let's see how many of you know
your Disney history when was Disneyland
opened
1956 right it's been around 68
years it makes more money for Disney now
than it did 10 years ago and definitely
more money than it did in the first 10
years Disney World Is Almost 53 years
old makes more money for Disney now than
it did 10 20 30 years ago I remember the
first few years of Euro dis Disney
people talked about how much of a
disaster it was because it was losing
money now Euro Disney is a cash cow you
see where I'm going with these right big
infrastructure investments in the first
10 years you're catching them in the
worst 10 years of their history just
before they become cash
CS so while 10 years might seem like
it's a fair life to use for every
investment it's extremely unfair to your
really long-term Investments to cut them
off after 10 years and say hey the
project didn't pay off
so one of the problems with accounting
returns that you can't easily get over
is you have to stop somewhere and if
that somewhere is too short for a given
project you can end up penalizing a
project not because it's a bad project
but because you cut it off at the prime
of its
life we'll come back and talk about
something we can do about it but not
much we can do in an accounting return
perspective you got to stop this summer
now I'm going to go on a little tangent
here with return on Capital because this
has become a metric that gets used in
consulting firms in banking all the
time what I computed with the theme park
was a return on capital for a new
project but if you think about what goes
to return on Capital it's after tax
operating income on the project divided
by the book value of capital invested in
the
project I can compute an accounting
return on capital for an entire ire
company here's what I'll do I'll take
the after tax operate income for the
companies we take Disney 6.92 billion
that comes right off the income
statement and I'll go to the balance
sheet and I take Book value of e Equity
plus book value of debt minus cash it's
called invested
Capital I'm essentially taking the
entire company and treating it as if
it's a gigantic project what I get is a
return on capital is 12.61% you're
saying what does that tell me to the
extent that I trust a accountants
because remember you're completely
trusting accountants to get that
aggregate number Disney as a company
earns 12.61% on its existing projects
remember we talked about a financial
balance sheet company things that a
company's already done are existing
Investments Assets in place here's a
question I'm asking is is the know
before I get ambitious about the future
are the company's existing Investments
good Investments neutral Investments or
bad Investments and to make the Judgment
I compare the return on Capital to the
cost of capital the collective cost of
capital of the company and at least in a
very crude sense Disney looks like it's
earning about 4.8% more than its cost of
capital
why whenever you get a number you can
get a you'll get this number for your
company trust me I will force you there
and you will get a number for your
company I wanted to stop and ask the
question why what is it about Disney
that allows it to earn more than the
cost of
capital in econ 101 when you have
perfect competition no company earns
more than its cost of capital because
the minute you do that competition comes
in and wipes it out so the very fact
that you're earning more than the cost
of capital means that you're not just
not in perfect competition but there are
some barriers entry some competitive
advantages that the company has with
Disney that should be easy to ident ify
right what is it that allows Disney to
earn more than its cost of
capital and in fact it's more than it's
a mouse with big
ears I mean let's face it a huge chunk
of value comes from those Legacy and now
you've added to that you got the
Avengers you got essentially it's a
collection of characters that over time
have become a competitive so you can
start a theme park build everything that
Disney built all the rides but you have
no Mickey mini or Avengers you're not
going to track the same number of people
or even a fraction of those people the
competitive Advantage here comes from
images is that
permanent that you will continue to do
this do brand names fade sometimes
absolutely in fact Disney came awfully
close to that happening about 15 20
years ago we'll talk about it or 40
years ago 198 80s it looked like the
brand name was fading Walt Disney had
been you know had passed away there was
decade after this and nobody could
figure out where to go next it's not
permanent but for the moment it looks
like they're earning more than the cost
of capital and I do that for all of my
companies and all of them earn more than
their cost of capital except for
bookscape but the only reason it earns
less is because of that total cost of
capital penalty remember the owner not
Diversified I used to Total beta
four of my five companies earn more than
the cost of
capital and you're saying of course
they're going to earn more than their
cost of capital they're big publicly
traded companies do most big publicly
traded companies earn more than their
cost of capital you think me after all
they should be the cream of the crop
right they rise to the top they get
publicly
listed what do you
think kind of an empirical
statement start of every year one of the
most depressing things I do is I compute
the return on capital for every publicly
traded company that's not the depressing
part that's pretty mechanical but I've
got to clean up for things so accounting
returns you got to clean up for the fact
that the accountants don't do the right
things when it comes to leases and R&D
and sometimes they get in the way of
you're trying to compute numbers by
writing off their mistakes do you see
why writing off your mistakes makes your
return on Capital misleading because you
write off your mistake invested Capital
goes down and the year after I don't
even know you wrote it off and you look
like you're a great company because you
earn more than your cost of capital so I
do these CLE this exercise of cleaning
up I computer return capital for every
company 48,000 publicly traded companies
I get the return cap for each company I
compute the cost of cap for every
company again it's pretty mechanical
risk free I do everything in dollar
terms to keep it Apples to Apples so the
risk free rate is the t- bond rate I
used to bottom up beta for every company
an equity risk premium reflecting where
they're incorporate and operate so I
have a return capital and cost capital
for each of the 48,000 companies and I
do a very simple comparison did you earn
more than your cost of capital remember
I'm 4 for four right if you look across
all companies that is the most
depressing statistic I look at every
year take a look globally 48
47,700 firms
27% earned a return on Capital that was
greater than the cost of capital that's
a very kind way of saying 73% of
companies earn less than their cost of
capital some will have good excuses
right or good reasons they could be
young companies they still haven't built
up to earning returns could be commodity
companies and commodity prices did
badly but about about 40% of these
companies have earned less than their
cost of capital every year for the last
years what does that tell me you're in a
bad
business what's your first reaction when
a company's in a bad business
why don't they just stop right liquidate
themselves the only promise you're not
going to get your Capital back if you're
in a bad business and everybody knows
you're in a bad business you try to sell
the business you're not going to get
your Capital back you're kind of stuck
but the one thing you can tell them is
if you're a bad business how much should
they try to
grow why you even thinking about growth
you should be shrinking I've never
understood airlines that try to grow
what's wrong with you guys one of the
worst businesses in the world to be in
you expand you're expanding in a in a
bad business what's the endgame here so
when you look at your company and you
get your company's return on Capital
don't be surprised if the return on
capital is less than the cost of capital
look for reasons maybe there's a good
reason other than it being a bad
business and a bad company but if you
can't find any reasons your conclusion
might be my company has slipped into a
bad business it started as a as a good
business 30 40 50 years ago but it's no
longer a good business so if you get a
chance go back and re you know a few
weeks ago I wrote a post on the 10 worst
businesses in the world to be in right
businesses like Telecom become a bad
business right Airlines
automobiles banking is increasingly slid
into the bad business column used to be
a good business 20 years ago things
change and sometimes good businesses
become bad businesses any questions on
return Capital so if you hear a banker
use the word
Roy there's no magic here it's return
and invested Capital it comes with flaws
it's a nice number to know but I'm not
going to build an entire story on a
single accounting number until I've
checked it out and made sure that the
number reflects where the company is
right
now so that's your accounting return and
careful the theme park let's return to
the Rio Disney theme park remember the
measure of a good A good measure of
investment return is based on cash flows
those cash flows should be incremental
and there should be time weighted did
the accounting return on Capital meet
any of those
standards first was it based on cash
flows accounting return Capital no it's
based on earnings so already did it
reflect incremental no I threw
everything in there right allocated
cause is it time waited I just took a
simple average it is the worst
conceivable way you can measure returns
so you say why do we spend time doing it
because half of all investment decisions
around the world are still based on
accounting returns return Equity return
invested Capital so it's a flawed
measure you can see why people use it
it's an accounting measure and if you're
an account if you come from an
accounting background you very quickly
gravitate towards it so I'd like to fix
it so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to take those accounting earnings
you saw for the project first convert
them into Cash flows it's going to be a
very mechanical exercise then make them
incremental cash flows and then time
weigh those incremental cash flows so
let's start with the first step right in
incidentally when you get a chance and
you catch up on your project after
you've done the cost of capital the
return capital is like a five minute job
you can compute it for last year see if
you're like one of my four companies
earning more than the cost of capital or
less but don't again be surprised if you
find your company earning less than the
cost of Capital it happens sometimes for
transitory reasons you're going to
become better or sometimes just because
you're in a bad
business so here's the first step I'm
going to take the accounting earnings on
this project and make it into cash flows
to make earnings go go from earnings to
cash flow three adjustments and I talked
about this in the last session first you
add back depreciation and amortization
why because they're non-cash expenses
they lowered your earnings you add them
back second I'm going to subtract out
Capital
expenditures so now you see a big number
popping up the billion dollars the
billion and half the 5 billion that I'm
investing over the first three years now
shows up as a cash outflow and finally I
bring in the change in working capital
remember again what change in working
capital does it makes acral earnings
Into Cash earnings so there are my cash
flows and you can compare my earnings to
my cash flows and you notice first that
the numbers are more negative up up
front that's the initial investment now
P showing up in my cash flows but over
time the cash flows start to get higher
than the earnings so it's what you're
essentially doing is you're restoring
balance to this project by bringing in
everything involved and reflecting when
the cash flows happen so I want to focus
in on those three adjustments and talk
about what effect they have on Project
analysis so let's let's start with
appreciation seems like we're wasting
time right because to get to earnings I
subtracted our depreciation and now
we're adding it back again so you're
saying why even waste your time on
depreciation in fact there are Bankers
who use Eid da as a starting point of
operating income saying why subtract our
da and then add back da is there a
reason we go through that step even
though it looks like more work what is
the effect of
depreciation that requires you to do
what we did subtracted out to get to
earnings and then add it back what
effect is the appreciation
have t
me it affects your
taxes it reduces your taxes paid
depreciation matters because it saves
you taxes and how much does it save it's
actually very simple take the
depreciation amount multiplied by a tax
rate that is the tax benefit you get
from depreciation so in this case I took
the depreciation numbers each year I
multiplied it by the 36.1% tax rate I
get the tax tax savings from
depreciation that's why we do what we do
with depreciation it's because it saves
you taxes which leads you to a couple of
propositions one the higher your tax
rate the more you're going to benefit
from depreciation so if your tax rate is
40% and minus 20% you will get a bigger
tax benefit from depreciation than I
will you see how this is going to open
the door to a certain kind of business
right let's suppose I'm at a very
Capital intensive business I have to buy
aircraft my tax rate is
20% your tax rate is 40% right so if I
buy the aircraft and I depreciate them I
get a 20% tax
benefit is there a way you can see an
opening for the for a business year what
could you conceive as a 40% tax rate
individual shy how would you exploit the
fact that your tax rate is higher than
mine to get a bigger tax benefit you
don't need the aircraft obviously I need
the aircraft but could you buy the
aircraft and lease it to
me by doing it what do you gain you get
the benefits of depreciation you will
share some of those benefits with me the
leasing business in the 60s and 70s was
born from the fact that individual tax
rates were much higher than corporate
tax rates and you could exploit that
difference like one reason the leasing
business suffered in the as those tax
rates converge you took away a big
reason for leasing so first is the
higher tax rate the greater the tax
benefit dep
depreciation which leads me to my second
proposition which is if you're a
nonprofit what the heck are you even
doing depreciating stuff who
cares I've seen nonprofits hire
accountants to depreciate stuff and no I
don't care it doesn't make a
difference and there are some non-cash
charges that are not tax deductible
there's some
amortization in which case I'll say just
ignore them then they're going you going
to reduce them then add them back
there's no effect the reason we care
about depreciation is because it affects
your
taxes so when you depreciate things
you're going to get a tax benefit that
increases your value to the project in
fact a lot of green projects so-called
green projects a big chunk of the value
comes from tax benefits you get from tax
credit and expensing and depreciation
not from the actual selling of energy
from that project it's I think the the
weakest link in green energy is how
dependent it's become on Ta on the tax
code and what that tax code does in
terms of providing benefits on that
project any questions on
depreciation yes you a question or you
just you're stretching
okay now when you depreciate things of
course of course you're spreading an
item out right once in a while though
you will get a choice between being able
to expense something or depreciate over
time in fact if you're a small business
I think up to 50,000 in Capital
Equipment you can actually expense
rather than depreciating saying why
would I want to do that let's see what
the effect is okay so when you look at
depreciation you can actually have two
types of depreciation one is straight
line depreciation you take the amount
You' spend and write it off in equal
amounts every year nice mathematically
easy to work with or you have all these
different depreciation methods where you
can get more of the depreciation earlier
rather than later it's called
accelerated depreciation lots of
different Sub sub approaches so I want
you to First think in terms of what
effect this will have on the earnings
for your project and then think about
the effect on the cash flows so let's
say that I have to pick between straight
line and accelerated but I care about
earnings I want to report higher
earnings on my project which one would I
go with Derek accelerated depreciation
will give me a higher earnings remember
depreciation is an expense right so if I
write off more in depreciation it'll
actually give me lower earnings up front
higher later but in terms of cash flows
accelerated depreciation will give me
more tax benefits right now you see why
you're tone between having reporting
better earnings and better cash flows
you know know that most us companies
have two sets of books it's completely
legal there's tax books which they use
to compute their taxes where they use
one type of depreciation and Reporting
books which you and I see where they use
a second type of
depreciation guess which one they use in
the tax books the most accelerated
depreciation you can get because you
want to get the biggest tax
benefits whereas in the reporting books
and where it shows up is in this
different
tax item or something that they have to
do to show so it's it's visible if you
look for it but it's completely
legal and you can see the game they want
to report higher earnings and have the
higher cash flows they're getting to eat
their cake and have it
too it gets even more of an issue when
you think about the capital expenditure
because remember depreciation comes from
Capital expenditures Capital
expenditures are Cash Out flows we we
Factor them in but I wanted to think
about two types of capital
expenditures one is maintenance capex so
let's go back to the theme park
maintenance capex is replacing one ride
with a new ride so basically what you
know whatever the you know the Dumbo
ride with some other ride why because
you got to get so it's maintenance capex
because you're not expanding the theme
park you're just
replacing equipment that's expensive
that'll give you benefits over many
years growth capex is building an entire
add-on to the so when California
Adventure was built at Disneyland that
was a growth capex it was a theme park
across from the old theme park why did
Disney build it because it wanted more
people to come to the theme park you
saying who cares they're both negative
cash flows you're right they're both
negative cash flows but depending on
your Ambitions for the project you might
have more of one than the other they
both drain cash flows and because they
drain cash flows you have to bring them
in the one thing you have to do when you
do project estimates you have to be
internally consistent you see what I
mean by internally consistent you tell
me that the number of people coming to
the theme park are going to increase by
15% a year I'll go along with it but
what do I need to see as growth capex if
you do that you got to be building more
additions to your team park because you
can't have people coming in overcrowding
the theme park and have no place to
go so what you assume about growth cap
has to be consistent with what you
assume about how long your project will
last and what you think will happen to
the project it's your assumptions
essentially being consistent with your
numbers and here again I'm going to give
you a choice there said many small
businesses you're given the choice
between expensing something or
capitalizing into de appreciating it and
again I'm going to ask you the question
in terms of what will that do to my
earnings and how will it affect my cash
flows so let's say that you're a
streaming company you're competing
against Disney and
Netflix and you spend let's assume a
$100 million acquiring customers you
know and your accountant says look you
can expense a 100
million right away you can spread it out
over
time first from an earnings perspective
would you rather expense something or
capitalize into depreciate
to capitalize and appreciated because
spreading things out gives you higher
earnings for the early years but from a
cash flow
perspective you always choose to expense
it again you can see two sets of books
right if I'm given two choices I'm going
to expense everything in my tax books
and claim the tax benefit right away but
my reporting books I am going to
depreciate amorti spread over time
because it again allows me to have
higher earnings my reporting books and
higher cash
flows in the case I've tried to kind of
be clear about what the capital
expenditures are so if you come to a
fork in the road where you have a choice
and remember you don't always have the
choice the tax code lays out what you
can
expense you're going to expense things
if you can pull that off but most of the
time you're constrained by what the law
allows the tax law allows you to expend
some things but the rest have to be
capitalized and spread out over time
and finally working
capital in the abstract working capital
is just a line item right inventory
receivables but if you get a chance walk
down bleer check out the retail stores
wait a week walk down bleer again
there'll be three new stores where the
old stores were I have seen in I mean
that street the turnover in in stores is
just incredible part of the reason is
the lease cost is really high but part
of the reason I think in many small
businesses is when people assess whether
to start the business they think in
terms of what they make in terms of
earnings and what they invest and say
that looks like a pretty good
investment but if you walk in any of
those stores and you look around you see
a lot of inventory and not much foot
traffic you have inventory and not much
foot traffic you have a problem why
because while that stuff is hanging or
sitting on the shelves or hanging on the
racks it's not making you any money the
reason you have to bring working capital
into your assessment is you can be
earnings rich and cash poor you see what
I mean earnings rich now you basically
report the earnings but you're not
collecting know so if you've given rece
so if you're selling on credit you
basically have receiveables if you have
inventory sitting around you know you
haven't recorded it your earnings rich
in cash per and unfortunately when the
bank comes calling it's cash that you
need to pay them so you can go bankrupt
even though your books look really good
so the reason we bring a working capital
in to to begin with is to capture that
effect so anytime I increase my working
capital that drains my cash flows
anytime I decrease my working capital
now do you see why marketing and finance
is often going to be at loggerheads
marketing wants you to carry the most
Styles you can and the most choice
because customers like it you go to a
shoe store you and you ask for a size
you want the person to go to the back
and come back with that shoe size right
so the marketing post say carry every
style in every size which makes sense
but the problem is that's going to
increase your inventory needs and you
might say look I'll take the top 20 most
popular models I'll carry it in every
size but I'm not going to carry every
size in models where I sell only five
shoes a year that's a working capital
effect and that's a healthy discussion
to have because you can't just carry
everything from the perspective of this
will make my customers happy if you
can't survive as a business you know in
my view a lot of project analysis the
failure comes from not even having a
working capital line item because you
don't think of it as an expense right
you think of your traditional accounting
expenses you don't think of the cash
flow effect of how much inventory do I
have to
carry you know until Walmart came along
the rule in retailing used to be that
your current assets had to be twice your
current liabilities
that's they know every account the
accounting textbook is current ratio
should be two healthy companies have
current ratios of two if you think about
a retailer and I maintain a current
ratio of two that's a huge drain on my
cash flows so Walmart came along so why
does it have to be two why can't I make
my current assets roughly equal to my
current liabilities and they went to
work on it right they created much more
updated inventory systems they were
among the first companies that scanned
inventory and essentially made sure that
you didn't have you know 15 15 of some
item you were not selling they also
squeeze their suppliers not the most you
know think about it squeeze the
suppliers in what sense you're selling
to Walmart Walmart is 60% of your sales
as a small producer they said we'll pay
you in 60
days and they got the cash right away so
they're using the float they basically
made their working capital into a
neutral item they didn't make it into a
but if you make working capital into
neutral item and you're a company the
size of Walmart that's $3 billion in
additional cash flows every year this is
a small item for some businesses but it
can be a huge one for others so when you
look at working capital and you can find
ways to reduce your working capital
always think about the tradeoff Because
by itself you're saying why don't I make
my working capital zero because you
might lose customer sales when they come
and say you don't have my size so it's a
tradeoff that you got to work with to
see if you can get that right balance
between having just enough inventory to
meet your customer needs and not so much
that you're drowning under your own
inventory requirements so when you look
at depreciation capex and working
capital don't think of them as line
items put some flesh on them think about
what they do to your project your
investment you know whatever you've
decided to put your money in any
questions on working
capital can you actually have negative
working capital for a
project I gave you a door right with in
the case of Walmart what do they do they
squeeze their suppliers and they
insisted on being paid right away you
can build a project where actually
working capital becomes a source of
capital for you to expand the project
it's not a very good way to do this
because if you scale up eventually it's
going to catch up with you but if you
can pull it off you can see a way in
which you can extract cash flows from
working
cap so we've gone from earnings to cash
flows any question on that adjustment so
add depreciation and non-cash charges
subtract capex subtract change in
working capital now I want to go to
incremental cash flow there are two
items I want to mop up on the first was
if you remember when I gave you the
original description of the project and
I told you it cost 5 billion to build
the the Magic Kingdom in Epcot I also
mentioned that half a billion of that 5
billion had already been spent and I
also said you're not going to get the
half a billion back if you decide not to
take the
project this is something that in
finance we tend to gloss over we have a
rule but it's actually one of the
toughest things as human beings to do is
ignore what's already happened when you
make a decision it's called the sun
cost and if you watch Guan Carlos stand
and you say what the heck were you
thinking giving him a 10-year contract
you're seeing a sunk cost payout right
which is the person who created the cost
is still running the team Brian Cashman
in the minute you admit to that mistake
it's a you know so we'll talk about
somea and why we have so much trouble in
decision making on okay the second thing
I told you was about that GNA remember I
said when I allocated the GNA that 2/3
of that GNA was going to be there no
matter what that's not an incremental
cost so here's the question you're
asking when you think about what's
incremental what'll happen if I take the
project what'll happen if I don't take
the project the answer is the same to
both those questions that item is not
incremental let's take the sun cost you
spent a half a billion right what will
happen if you take the project you spent
the half a billion what will happen if
you don't take the project you spent the
half a billion what difference is this
project made absolutely
nothing that allocated GNA the 2 th has
nothing to do with the project what'll
happen if you take the project it'll get
allocated to this project what'll happen
if you don't take the project it's going
to get allocated somewhere else it's not
like the company is going to save that
money by not taking the
project so to adjust for the sun cost
the the easy one was the half a billion
that I just took it off the initial
investment so I said look $2 and half
billion dollar is the total cost but
half a billion of that is sunk I
shouldn't be counting it when I make my
decisions and as far as the allocated
GNA I added back the 2/3 that was not
directly related to this project there's
a little tax effect that I've have to go
to clean up for because I claimed a tax
reduction so I've cleaned up for both of
the non-incremental items what you see
here now is my incremental cash flow
we're slowly moving towards our good
measure of return an incremental cash
flow time weighted return we've gone
from earnings to cash flows cash flows
to incremental cash
flows now I'll give you a very simple
illustration of that of of of an
incremental cost until about 10 years
ago I used used to do the training
program for every Investment Bank they
all used to be in August and I'd go bank
to bank to bank and after the fifth bank
I had no idea which bank I was in was
two day three-day programs so and they
used to you know many of them used to
have their training programs in one of
the hotels up toown like the Hilton
because they have big rooms and they
used to hire like 400 analysts in the
room so this was towards the end of an
August I was tired they were
tired and you know I give the talk you
know and there there's almost no
interaction in the room because we're
both ready to get out of there but
there's this person who was catering who
was setting up the the tables outside he
was the most you know he followed the
session more intently than anybody in
the room including me the end of the
first day he comes to me and says I have
a question for I've been listening all
day and I said okay what's your question
he said I'm from
Guatemala and um every year I fly back
home to visit my family it cost me about
$1,000 and every year I buy seconds you
know seconds are closed the gap which
have damage in them that I buy seconds
at at these big stores and I take them
with me to sell in Guatemala I make
about
$500 from selling and he said all my
accounting friends are telling me I
should stop doing this he is how the
accounting mindset works right it cost
you $1,000 to go to Guatemala you make
only $500 selling these clothes what's
the net bottom line us
500 they tell me I should stop doing it
but I have a feeling that they're not
right and I said you should stop having
accounting
friends because what is the missing
ingredient here what's a question that
they needed to ask him before they said
you should stop doing it are you going
to fly back anyways and he said of
course my family is there in which case
that minus 1,000 is not an incremental
cost it's a cost that's going to be a
might as well reduce it to minus 500
you're better off
but that's the that's the end game here
is rather than let something that's
going to all always be there stop you
from making a decision at least you make
it less painful so let's focus in on uh
on this notion of incremental cash flows
the way I got to my incremental cash
flows was was kind of indirect I did
earnings first and then I had to clean
up and it's often messy doing that so
you can do this on your project for
instance on the Celsius e project you
can do the earnings and then adjust for
cash flows but I'd strongly recommend
that you test it out with a second way
because that way you can see make sure
you got it right focus on just the
incremental items so don't do the entire
GNA do only the portion of the GNA
that's direct ignore the sunk cost so
effectively I'm going to end up with the
same answer the numbers are going to be
the same but I didn't have all that
cleaning up to do because I didn't have
to have an intermediate stop and
earnings so incremental cash flow
effects basically focus on incremental
revenues incremental expenses
incremental GNA and you come up with
incremental earnings and incremental
cash
flows but let's take a pause and talk
about Sun
cost every Corporate Finance textbook
you open up the advice is simple ignore
Sun cost I'm going to give you a weekly
exercise this week that's going to be
extremely painful for some of you to
do I'm going to talk
about the cost of your MBA
and then the expected potential benefits
of your MBA and I'm going to ask you to
compute a net present value of your
decision how many tuitions have they
collected from you
already two right usually they collect
right up front right they don't let you
stay till the end of the semester and
then pay so half your tuition has been
paid
already so it should be based on
incremental cash flows
right but the truth is you think about
what you B it's tough to leave that
behind psychologically leaving some
cause behind I mean imagine standing in
line for concert
tickets you gave yourself 30 minutes
during lunch for the concert tickets an
hour later you're still standing in line
you know you should leave right away but
what does your mind tell you you've
already spent an hour doing this that's
now going to be
wasted it's
psychological but it does affect our
decisions so when you think about some
cost it's easy to create the rule but
it's ignored in practice all the time in
fact there was an experiment that was
run about 20 25 years ago it's called
the conquered experiment basically there
were two groups of people you know they
they were B both both given the facts on
a new investment a new aircraft a
company was going to
make the first one was told about the
new aircraft and then they were told but
there's a comparative who actually come
up with a much better aircraft than we
have even though we've spent time would
you do it and they said no of course we
should because they were given the
earnings and cash flows the second group
were was given exactly the same
information but we're also told we've
spent $5 billion spending know building
this aircraft should we do it and many
of them chose to do it because it
already spent 5 billion CL classic
example of how some cost q a decision
making so it's something that know Psy
olist so this is part of Behavioral
finance that we've discovered is it's
very difficult for people to leave some
cause behind my advice when you have to
present a project analysis especially if
it's a project where the incremental
effects don't talk about what you've
already spent and how much time you
spent it's almost guaranteed to lead to
bad decision making because those some
costs are going to skew the decision so
some cause we know what to do but at the
same time it's very difficult to do it
so here's a simple example of how cost
become
sunk you're a consumer product company
you've spent aund million on test
marketing remember McDonald's does that
you know they have a little barbecue
thing that they come up with and then
take it off the menu let's say you spent
$100 million in the test marketing and
looking forward at what's coming you
think the project will create 25 million
based on expected future cash flow so
you've already spent 100 so what does
every Finance textbook tell you well
ignore the sun cost take the project
it's better to make the 25 million and
make the loss 75 million instead of 100
million financially that is actually the
right thing to do but if every single
project this happens you know what I
mean by this happening you spend a 100
million first and then say a sun cost
then you make 25 million how long will
you last as a
business not very long
this is the story of
R&D at many farmer companies right R&D
by the time it's spent it's become a
sunk cause by the time you get to the
decision of whether you should do
something the three billion you spent
developing the drug has become a sunk
cost well but early on pharmaceutical
companies when they had pricing power
complete pricing power would say not a
problem we'll just price it in but if
you start to lose pricing power and you
continue to let R&D spend money first
you're sunk as a pharmacal company so he
saying what choice do we have you
actually have to have a first level
assessment before you spend the R&D
given the uncertainty in the process and
say should we even be investing in R&D
because once you spend the money it's
way too late to try to get that money
back so we know what to do with some
costs and if you look at this you know
you should take the investment but you
clearly have to think if this is the
pattern that you're going to follow in
fact this morning it would have been
pure coincidence I get an email from
somebody who works at at a you know at a
company he's Computing the irr for a
project and he said when I compute the
irr for a project we IR is basically a
Time weighted incremental cash flow
return based on the future he said
should I include some cost he didn't use
a word he called it pre-project
Investments and I gave him my answer was
no and yes no if you're using it for
your decision making right because your
decision should be based on what's
coming and yes because you need to keep
track of the economics of your projects
internally as a company because this
keeps happening you're in a bad business
you might want to stop that spending 100
million up front before you make that
choice but I think we need to keep track
of both things which is on an
incremental basis we need to ignore Sun
costs but as a business we need to think
about the economics of our projects and
that requires thinking about what we
spend up front as well even though it's
sunk any questions on sun cost so think
about all the sun costs in your lifetime
because we all make personal choices
that become Sun cost and think of how it
affects our decisions because then
you're going to see this play out on a
much bigger scale in businesses with
hundreds of millions or even billions of
dollars which brings us to allocated
cost no it told you allocated GNA is
this gigantic expense item looking for
something to attach it to it's an every
large firm it's a big chunk of what gets
attached to a
project even at smaller firms you see
the show to the degree that your
projects creates additional GNA cost of
course you should Factor them in they're
incremental but it's it's only an
allocated cost and it's going to go
somewhere else counting it in is going
to lead you to reject Investments for
all the wrong reasons so when we when we
add back that allocated GNA that's what
we're trying to do so one of the
questions you often face is in the
problem you know in the case I gave you
what that incremental GNA was you saying
but in real the real world how would I
know how much GNA is incremental and how
much is fixed I'll give you a very
simple example and maybe you can work
out an extension of this for a company
it's not for the Celsius case but in
general for any company let's suppose
that I gave you the revenues and the GNA
costs for a
company your one year two your three
right is there a way that you can tease
out from the data how much of the GNA
cost in your three take the 300 million
your three how much of the GNA cost is
fixed and how much is
variable Leon you want to help me out
here so what's the definition of a
variable cost
that should move with revenues right so
if you look at my pattern I've kept the
numbers kind of easy to work with when
my revenues go up by 200 million my GNA
went up by 20 million went up by 300
million so looks like for every $100
million in revenues I get an additional
10 million in GNA right one way to think
about how much is fixed is make your
revenues go to zero we your catastrophic
event for your company you make your
revenues goore to zero what will happen
to my GNA
it's 10 million for every 100 million
Revenue so I go from 1500 to zero my GNA
will drop by 150 million it doesn't drop
to zero there's still 150 million left
over that's exactly how Hotel companies
felt in 2020 the revenues dropped to
zero because of covid you know you had
nobody traveling but their cost did not
go to zero because a big chunk of their
cost with fixed cost Airbnb in contrast
the revenues went to toward zero the GNA
cost also went toward zero because
almost all of it was connected to the
revenues it's not a perfect measure
there are lots of noise in it but if you
take your company's history of revenues
and GNA cost you can start to e out from
it how much of how much is fixed and how
much is variable so in this case 150
million is fixed GNA another 150 million
is variable GNA and that's good to know
when you think about how much should I
be attaching to my project because that
fix
GNA is what kills you when you start
allocate to project because it's going
to be there no matter what you
do we gone from earnings to cash flows
cash flows to incremental cash flows
let's talk about time
waiting time waiting is just the time
value of money right just
discounting and in a sense we've already
laid the foundations for what discount
rate we should be
using these cash flows are cash flows
from a Disney Rio theme park and we've
already concluded that the cost of
capital for the theme park is 8.46% we
have our discount rate we have our cash
flows I'm almost ready to Discount those
cash flows every year when I remember
that 10year problem that I had at the
end of year 10 when I got my return on
Capital I said I wish I could go longer
but it's so much
work is there a way I can stop in your
10 and then bring in what happens after
you your 10 without explicitly going
your 11 year 12 year 13 if I'm working
with incremental cash flows Constantine
what what can I do sorry I'm going to
come up with an estimate of how much
this project is worth at the end of your
10 based on an assumption a kind of
General assumption what happens after
your 10 I mean in discounted in valuing
companies we call this the terminal
value but basically it's a continuing
value for the theme
par now you saying for how long
well I could go an extra 15 years an
extra 20 years an extra 30 an extra 50
but here's the advantage once you get
past years 30 40 50 you might as well go
forever what's the advantage of going
forever well you can actually get the
present value of the cash flows forever
much more easily than getting the
present value cash flows in extra 15
years mathematically it's easier to work
with I know most of you don't work with
time value equations but I'm kind of I
don't believe that present value
function in Excel even after using it 30
years I never use it I prefer to build
in my present value equations and it's
not rocket science there are only five
kinds of cash flows you will ever run
into in finance it covers the Spectrum
you can have a single cash flow in the
future what would that be like well if I
told you that you have a $40 million
payment coming due in 30 years what's
the value of it today that's a single
cash
flow you can have an annuity what's an
annuity a constant cash flow every year
for a period of time so your one sod and
I say I'll pay you 70 million every year
for the next 10 years that's an annuity
there's equation for a present value of
an annuity that's the payment button and
the in a standard calculator or in Excel
the present value of an annuity you can
have a growing annuity which almost
never is built into a calculator but
it's actually a nice equation to have
what's a growing annuity I have a gold
mine creates a million dollars in cash
flows I expect to grow 3% year for the
next 25 5 years and then there's no more
gold left in the mine and I say how much
is this gold mine worth there are two
ways I can compute the present value I
can do the cash flows the next 25 years
discount every cash flow back or in one
equation I can get the present value of
those cash flows if you don't believe me
take it and work it out with the numbers
it's a growing
annuity and then the last two are kind
of mind bogged their cash flows that
last forever you can have a perpetuity
which is a single cash flow every year
forever the British and the Canadians
used to have they're probably still
around bonds called console bonds
console bonds you got a coupon every
year in perpetuity reflects the optimism
of those age that forever they've
stopped doing it right but you got to
fix gu that's a
perpetuity or you have an even more
mind-blowing concept which is a growing
perpetuity growing perpetuity you got a
cash flow growing at a constant rate
forever this is the most misused
equation in finance but what is it allow
you to do it allows you to take a cash
flow growing at 2% a year forever and
come up with the present value with one
equation everything in finance is some
combination of the equations what what
know what are the two cash flows that
make go into a traditional Bond what do
you get every year you get a coupon
which is an annuity at the end of the
lifetime you get a face value which is a
single cash flow you want to value a
stock well if you assume the cash cash
flows will last forever if it's a high
growth comp company you have cash flows
of the high growth period could be a
growing annuity and then you get to your
five or 10 you say well it's only going
it's the growth rate is now low enough
to be forever a growing annuity plus a
growing
perpetuity take any security out there
and you can break it out into its cash
flows and you have the present value
components to come up with the value so
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
get to year 10 on my theme park I'm
going to stop estimating cash flows but
after year 10 I'm going to bring what
happens after year 10 into the value
that I assigned to this theme park at
the end of year 10 and I'm going to use
two decision rules both of which use
time weighted cash
flows but may be useful in different
contexts the first is called The Net
Present Value what is the Net Present
Value I take each cash flow discounted
back to today add up the present values
and I come up with the sum of those
numbers nice thing about npv is it's
greater than zero
you accept the project if it's less than
zero you reject the project and that
that sometimes know seems like you know
difficult to get through let's say you
have a b project where you spend a
billion dollars and I tell you the net
present value is $10 what's your
reaction going to be that's not enough I
spent a billion how do you explain to
somebody that we have an investment that
costs you billions and even having a 10
million or a $10,000 npv is still okay
how do you explain
that Chris what do you think how does
now how do you get through to somebody
big investment up front you come up with
this really small npv that it's still
okay Z Los option it's a little more
than that right npv is over and above
your cost to Capital so I'm not not
making I'm making the the 8.5% cost of
capital plus an extra $10 would I rather
make another 10 billion absolutely but
remember that table I showed you 73% of
the world struggles to earn zero Net
Present Value you earn $10 you're
already in the winning side of the
equation so small Net Present values as
long as they're positive are over and
above the cost of capital I'm going to
take it but the problem with npv it's a
dollar number we don't think in dollar
terms we try T what did your portfolio
make last year you don't have to give
away too much you can make up a number
if you want
same the answer I got was a percentage
return right ask anybody what they did
the return is because we tend to think
in percentage terms npv is a do nobody
you ask them on a portfolio says my
portfolio made 16,38 in Net Present
Value they just give you a percentage
return an irr is a percentage time
weighted return what do you do you take
those cash flows in the initial
investment you solve for a discount rate
that makes your Net Present Value zero
the old days it was trial and error you
tried eight then you tried 12 then 9 and
11 now of course you H the IR button it
gives you an answer it's that discount
rate that makes your Net Present Value
zero a lot of people who use IR and I'll
give you the survey statistics and IR
versus npv you know what the reasoning
for using IR is we don't have to come up
with a discount rate and it's true right
technically to compute the IR you don't
need a disc Contra whereas for npv you
do but the problem is once you get
internal rate of return to make a
decision guess what you need you need a
hurdle rate you need a discount rate you
can't run away from that the question is
where do you bring it in so I'm going to
use both approaches for Disney but I'm
going to put in closure on this project
by assuming that after you attend the
theme park will keep going for how long
forever no this sounds incredibly
optimistic at Disneyland 500 years from
now I'll talk about why I'm okay with
the forever but I'm going to add some
constraints I'm going to assume that
after you attend the number of people
coming into the tee Park levels
off and that the increase in cash flows
will be roughly equal to the inflation
rate what am I effectively assuming that
the ticket prices will go up by the
inflation rate why am I putting in that
constraint that the number of tourists
are going to level off in year 10 if I
did not do that France what would I have
to do on this Steam
Park if if I say the number of tourists
are going to grow by 2% a year forever
what's going to happen to the theme park
you can have as many fast passes as you
want but the theme park is going to be
so crowded that people are going to come
in through the front gate and not be
able to move
right if I have to grow the number of
people coming it's a perfectly
appropriate assumption but then I have
to come up with an additional theme park
on expansion I don't want to do that I
want to keep the theme park as is keep
the number of tourists leveled up but
the cash flow will grow at the inflation
rate forever I have a growing perpetuity
I'm going to compute the present value
of that growing perpetuity by taking the
cash flows in year 11 you always have to
do that present value equations go an
extra year so there's my cash flow in
year 10 growing at 2% and divided by my
cost of capital and already you can see
why I needed that discount rate first to
do this minus the growth rate I come up
with this incredibly large number
11,275 million
I'm going to go put that in to your
10 and that HS the scale remember the
project did not look good on an
accounting return basis now when I
compute the net present value of the
cash flows using that 8.46% cost of
capital the npv that I get is 3.3
billion I actually did this for a group
at Disney 20 years ago the there were
two levels of push back one is they said
but even Disney team Parks don't last
forever and that's absolutely true
nothing lasts
forever so why am I using a perpetuity
because once you get to 50 or 60 years
the value that you get is roughly equal
to the perpetuity value and we said
Disneyland is already what 68 years so I
think that the project life is long
enough that you can get away with it if
you have a pain in the neck in in the
group who says I want to be precise
maybe you have an actuary in the group
once you 65 years conceded doing a
growing annuity you get roughly the same
answer as doing a perpetuity but we do
it for
convenience the second push back was a
little more
subtle this is the number that tilts the
scale right
11,275 million we know mathematically
where it came from taking the cash flow
here but what exactly is that
11,275 million intuitively give me a way
of explaining
what that number captures Patrick you
want to try what's
11,275
million I know no what does it mean
somebody who's not in finance so we can
use terminal value we all might get it
but let's say somebody who's a tee Park
guy
yeah the value of the theme park to
somebody
else Lo with everything in in it right
including Mickey Minnie the car which
means Disney will never sell the theme
park because you imagine Disney selling
a theme park with the characters in it
it's a hypothetical it's what you think
the theme park would be worth to
somebody else if you sold it Lock Stock
barrel and Mickey
included when you do terminal value
that's a way to think about the terminal
values what somebody will pay you based
on the cash flows on this theme park in
perpetuity and we're tying up that loose
end
so project is a good project the net
present value is 3.3 billion and here's
the nice thing about npvs the minute
Disney takes this theme park its value
as a company increases by 3.3 billion
npvs are additive every time you take a
positive Net Present Value project your
value goes up every time you take a
negative Net Present Value project your
value goes
down you know there are companies out
there that take projects n PVS of minus
5 billion no Microsoft took one with a
net PV of minus 10
billion and S Nella is great CEO what
are these projects that can have npvs of
minus 5 billion minus 10
billion and how can a project get that
big I mean it's got to be an immense
project right lose that much remember
when I talked about projects I described
all kinds of projects internal in
Investments I talked about
Acquisitions talked about strategic
Investments talk inventory reinvestment
which of those do you think is is has a
highest chance of being a minus5 billion
project how much did Microsoft pay for
Activision about 50 billion the day they
did the acquisition Microsoft lost 10
billion in market cap
why because investors looked and say we
don't see the upside here we don't see
the benefit you pay this premium over
the market price we don't see the
synergies you're talking about
here when you do a big bad acquisition
it's essentially the equivalent of
taking a negative Net Present Value
project the next time you see a new
story about an acquisition don't look at
the Target firm nothing interesting is
happening other than the stock price
going up look at the acquiring firm
because that's where you're going to see
that judge that investors are passing on
whether this is a zero Net Present Value
project a positive or A negative one and
I think I mentioned this towards the
start of the class 55% of Acquisitions
the acquiring Company stock price goes
down on the announcement at least
investors are passing judgment on this
is a negative Net Present Value
investment so npv is has this great
feature of being additive you can take a
company and actually write it as a sum
of the present values of all of the npvs
the Investments it's taken
but as I said npv is a dollar value
let's talk about
irr I know the way we compute irr is we
hit that IR button on Excel or you know
we get a number not only do I not quite
trust the number I think we lose a lot
of information when we do this so
instead of doing that IR calculation by
Computing that number from an Excel
spreadsheet or calculator I'm going to
do what's called an npv profile sounds
fancy but I take the cash flows I keep
them the same and I change my discount
rate usually when you raise the discount
rate the net present value is going to
go down you saying why isn't that always
we'll talk about know cases where they
might not in most projects raising the
discount rate in that P so I comput the
npv at 1% 2% 3% 4% 5% discount rates
what am I looking
for where the npv is zero where it
crosses the
line that's my internal rate of return
my IR for this project is 12.6% is that
a good irr what do I compare that to to
my cost Capital which is 88.4% so
basically it's a project with is that
always going to be the case if you have
a company with a positive
npv it's IR is going to be great greater
than the cost of
capital most of the time we'll talk
about exception of the rule but they're
exceptions most of the time the two
rules will converge because they share a
great deal right they're both time
weighted they're both incremental cash
flow returns say what do you gain by
doing
this notice the slope of that
line you know in fixed income
foundations you probably talked about
duration what is duration of a bond
measure sounds like a dumb question but
what is it
measure anybody
so price change I'm glad you because
usually people in ask some duration give
them give me time and so duration
measures when the cash flows come do
which is true but it's also a measure of
how sensitive your bond price is to
changes in interest rates when you have
a high duration
Bond and interest rates go up your bond
price will drop by more in fact it's a
slope of that line so if you graphed
bond price against interest rates it's a
slope of that line so high duration
bonds are in a sense riskier than low
duration bonds do you see the analogy
here what is this graph measure it
measures how sensitive your npv is to
your discount rate so let's say have two
projects that you're trying to pick
between between a Rio Disney project and
another project that has exactly the
same
npv but that project has a much flatter
line in other words it's much less
sensitive to Discount
rats this project because it's more
sensitive would be riskier to you as a
company because with the cost of capital
changes you're far more more likely to
see paid when you have a pro so that's
the additional information you get from
an npv profile that you will not
get by just Computing an IR for a
project so this Project's irr is 12.6%
it's higher than the cost of capital and
for the most part the two will move
together especially if you have a
standalone independent project like you
do here if you have to pick between
project you have to rank them things get
a little Messier but I think we spend
way too long talking about npv versus
irr when in fact once you've adopted one
or the other we're closer then using an
accounting return on capital or some
other measure of picking projects
they're both time weighted they're both
incremental cash flow based they both
pass the test of being good measures of
returns and in this case they're both
pushing in the same direction which is
this is a good
project just go out and take
it any questions on
the pth so basically take a look at
earnings to cash flows C because you
will be doing this on your Celsius each
project right you'll computer you know
you have to come up with the earnings
because I do ask you for return on
Capital I ask you for cash flows and
incremental cash flows I leave the
decision to use so you can use whatever
decision rule you want but ultimately
this is your money you work at Celsius
this is the company's money the share
olders money being invested in the snack
food business and you have to think
about does it create value or not
when I started my number crunching for
you I told you I was going to cheat and
do everything in Us doll cheating
because the project is in Rio the cash
flows are going to be in RIS right I
should be doing this everything in
R so without even looking at the numbers
I want you to think about what would
happen to the npv of this project if I
did everything in re so my cash flows
are going to be in re my discount rate
is going to be in re so let's start with
the discount rate when I go from a
dollar cost to Capital to re cost of
capital what will happen to my discount
rate
Carolina I'm
sorry your name is Carolina no okay
sorry now what's your name Amy Amy sorry
yeah what's uh so when you think about
doing everything in real I go from a
dollar discount rate to a r discount
rate how would I get from dollars would
the discount rate be higher or lower and
I go from dollars Tre
eyes you can call a friend right it's
like we can make it you
know Patrick you can help her if you
want so if I go from dollars to my
discount rate go up or go
down okay now you want to
try
yeah I would say
that that the r of the gap
so no no wait it's the same project
right so all I'm changing is the
currency the cash flow risk is not
changing it's still in R so none of that
is changing all I'm changing is the
currency
sh anybody want to try okay
good it'll go up but tell me why it's
going to go up it's not the risk going
up because it's the same project the
risk is the same why do currencies
matter stability but also with what's
the missing ingredient yeah inflation
right the r is a higher inflation
currency it's going to go up because
inflation is higher in R I'm going to
get a much higher cost of capital in
fact I'll show you how much higher it's
going to be 15.91% instead of 8 that's
terrible right High it is
contate it's because the inflation rate
in Brazil is 99% the inflation rate in
the US is 2% that's the only reason it's
not country RIS so when you switch from
currency to currency it's not like
you're looking at a different project
the same
project so my discount rate is going to
be 15.91%
let's go to the cash flows right my cash
flows were in dollars now I have to
convert them to reals so convert dollar
cash flows to R cash
flows what do I need
the same inflation rates right so
instead of having a 2% inflation rate
behind me I have a 9% inflation rate I'm
going to get much higher cash flows in
RIS because my growth rate is going to
be
higher it shows up through my exchange
rate there's this U there's this very
simple proposition that drives exchange
rates called purchasing power parody
what does that mean if you have one
currency with a 9% inflation rate the
other with the 2% inflation rate the
exchange rate over time on the higher
inflation rate currency it'll weaken the
higher inflation rate so if you look at
my starting point 2.35 RS per share by
the time I get to your 10 I'm getting
4.56 re entirely driven by exactly the
same inflation differential that draw my
discount rate already you can see where
I'm going to end up I have a much higher
discount rate 15.91% I have much higher
cash flows in Ras because I have that
same extra 7% helping me out each year
when I compute The Net Present Value The
Net Present Value that I end up with is
7.75 billion riads converted into
dollars I get exactly the same answer to
the nth decimal point as doing
everything in US Dollars it's almost
magical but why is it happening because
I'm making sure that when I raise my
discount rate for inflation I'm also
adjusting my cash flows for exactly the
same inflation this is incredibly good
news if you think about it because it
means you can pick your favorite
currency to work with and work with it
on any project anywhere in the world if
you stay consistent what gets us into
trouble is being
sloppy having one currency play out in
your discount rate one currency play out
in your cash flows the net effect can be
all over the place if you're not
careful so in this case I did everything
in dollars but I could have done
everything in R and I've got exactly the
npv and that should
intuitively be the right answer right a
good a project shouldn't be good in
dollars and bad in RS so good in you
know switching currencies that's like
saying you know I can change the
temperature by going from Fahrenheit to
Celsius you don't it just feels a little
cooler if you do things in Celsius
because the number is
lower but it's not changing currency
should not change the fundamental
characteristics of a project because the
riskiness the cash flows the margins are
all there it's just inflation effect so
I will end with that Wednesday when we
start we're going to you know talk about
uncertainty and then we're going to talk
about all these side effects so again
read the case if you haven't already
because it can help you in thinking
through the
yeah so